في الاثناء افاد مراسل الجزيره بانه وفدا
اماميا دخل الى مناطق شمال غرب سوريا من
معبر باب الهوى الحدودي مع تركيا واضاف
مراسلنا ان الوفد مؤلف من مديرين ومسؤولين
في الوكالات الامميه ومديره مكتب اوتشا في
غازي عنتاب اضافه الى نائب المناسق
الانساني الاقليمي للامم المتحده ياتي
دخول الوفد الامم قبيل دخول مساعدات امميه
مكونه من اثنتين شاحنه تحمل مساعدات
غذائيه وطبيه
اعرضها الدفاع المدني السوري في شمال
سوريا عن صدمته مما سماه تصرفات الامم
المتحده التي قال انها تمنح الرئيس السوري
بشار الاسد فرصه في ان تكون له كلمه بشان
المساعدات التي ستمر عبر المعابر الحدوديه
مع تركيا وقال مدير الدفاع المدني رائد
الصالح ان ذلك منح نظام مكاسب سياسيه
مجانيه وكان الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو قد اعلن ان الرئيس الاسد وافق على
سماحل الامم المتحده بتسليم مساعدات الى
مناطق المعارضه عبر معبارين حدوديين من
تركيا لمده ثلاثه اشهر